the features of the internet that we
really want to make sure persist and I
don't count on inertia to do the job
here but these features include the fact
that when we're surfing the web that
we're actually visiting lots of
different places the web of 1998 and
sort of through the past 10 years or so
has been one where there's lots of
baskets with eggs all over the place and
by just clicking on a link you can visit
that new basket and not even feel the
burdens of the journey it could be in a
basement in Chappaqua New York the
server you're going to it could be at
Amazon it could be somewhere in Europe
you name it anywhere around the world
that I think has been less and less so
and part of the research I'm working on
is to actually document and figure out
if that hypothesis is true I'm actually
concerned that because of worries about
things like denial of service attacks
where websites might be brought down
what we'll see our web sites huddling
under the umbrella of just a handful of
Internet service hosting providers so it
might feel like you're going from one
website to another when in fact all
you're doing is visiting one quarter of
the massive data banks at Amazon that
offers up commodity web hosting to the
world that puts all the eggs in one
basket which seems dangerous to me if
Amazon goes down everything goes down
not just your ability to one-click
purchase a mousetrap and it also means
that there are regulatory changes made
possible so that if a government of the
world wants something taken down or
dealt with they only have one door to
knock on and depending on your view of
how easily government should be able to
take stuff down that's either a good
thing or a bad thing so having a
distributed web with eggs across lots of
baskets is one thing that I hope will
persist the other thing is I hope the
web will persist you know the number of
times you might find yourself living
your digital life by running a browser
and typing in a link and then from the
trapeze going from one place to another
visiting each site and clicking on links
and typing stuff that's starting to feel
possibly very 2005 more and more the way
in which we experience the world or
through apps so if you were told you
could still use your smartphone but you
just can't load up the browser you can
only use apps and those apps might have
a browser quietly running in the
background but the experience you'll get
inside that app is so much more defined
by the app maker and you know if you're
looking at Facebook and you see the
sponsored links you're getting
importuning you to do something almost
always its bottom line please install
this app everybody wants you to install
their app and that's because it's
putting you inside the bottle of a
miniature universe that isn't
necessarily connected web-like to the
rest of things if you see something
interesting inside an app and you want
to share it it will be under the terms
of that app whether you can email the
link or whether you can only tweet it or
whether you can do anything with it
there's not a common URL that bar at the
top that you can just copy and paste and
share with a friend and then that friend
can see what you see so as I look to the
future really thinking about the future
of the web itself is something we we
ought to be doing I don't take for
granted that there will be a world wide
web the way that there has been it might
be much more stove-piped and feel a
little bit more like 1985 with an
america CompuServe prodigy and the
source okay you've got your apps those
apps in turn are there at the sufferance
of your mobile phone or your other
platform vendor it's a much more staid
possibility and so much of the benefits
of the Internet have come from unusual
corners from not being so staid I'd hate
to think oh those were the early days
things have matured now there is a
genuine worry about security that has it
no longer seem so crazy as it probably
did I think it did and say the year 2000
gee maybe before you run an app someone
out there should vet it should know who
wrote it should have their contact
information on file the way that if you
get into a taxicab
remember taxi cabs there'd be an
identity marker if you use an uber or a
lyft they have some way of knowing who
the drivers are they're registered if
that's the level of security you want
when you drive three blocks why wouldn't
you want that four code to which you are
entrusting your most intimate details
and more and more I think that's what we
see happening I don't know that that's
terrible but it does show a general
trend in the name of security in having
intermediaries be able to more tightly
control the code that we can run whether
it's on our device or afar and the
content that we can see